love was definitely in the air at the
ACM Awards unfortunately for Carrie
Underwood her hubby Mike Fisher wasn't
able to be there they're so great
together though they have an adorable
little boy so are they ready for more
led online so Keisha Lacy talk family
with country music's power mom so now
that Isaiah is officially - are you
thinking about having more kids are you
ready to expand the family um you know
we're just we're on God's good timing or
whatever you might call it I'm just
trying to trying to figure out where
life's gonna take me next does Isaiah
ever ask for a little brother or sister
oh no no as a matter of fact if a dog
like climbs up in my lap um he I feel
like he gets a little jealous so a
bigger family will have to wait and see
on that but one thing we know for sure
Kari is one hot mama check her out at
the ACM Awards where she had for
wardrobe changes a girl spends time at
the gym check out those legs
least favorite gym routine I don't know
if I have like a least favorite because
they all do something I just do whatever
carries a busy mom these days she was in
Vegas on Sunday and on California's
Catalina Island last night so she
doesn't get a lot of time off but when
she does you might be surprised by how
she spends it I clean my house and bake
try to make food and just spend time at
home with my family if there's a bag to
unpack I like to unpack it carries in
Catalina giving back to her fans
performing for military families on the
Carnival cruise ship imagination so
she's pretty much Supergirl but she does
have one weakness I loved all the cakes
that I've been seeing on your Instagram
yeah hey Kate yeah holy cow is my best
friend's a baker and she just knows me
so well well I'm gonna assume that that
birthday cake is chocolate Carrie said
that's her favorite flavor my favorite
flavor of cake is cake
[Music]